our main story tonight concerns
chocolate the star attraction in
Neapolitan ice cream nothing against
vanilla and strawberries just that one
is a euphemism for boring sex and the
other is fruit and fruit is simply not
dessert chocolate is the greatest just
watch as this baby get a first taste of
it okay one more one more really big one
ready are you ready
yeah baby same and and I hope it Savers
that chocolate High cuz I think we all
know the rest of Human Experience is
pretty much downhill from there
everybody loves chocolate that is why we
use it for everything from beauty
products to sculptures to breakfast
cereal although some arguably love it a
little too much like the host of this
cooking show there's a component a
substance and chocolate called fenel
ethylamine and what that fancy word does
is it slightly elevates your blood
pressure and your heart rate and they
tell me that it's a sensation that's not
unlike having an
orgasm I don't know maybe that's why
people love chocolate so much but anyway
let me get back to our step here
okay first what a long weird way to tell
people that you've never had an orgasm
second I can't believe that there is a
chem chemical that makes your brain
horny and they named it pheny ethyl aine
that is not a sexy name Erol seducti
lust dat aceline all of those are free
and available and just to be very clear
eating chocolate is nothing like having
an orgasm unless you count the fact that
when boys do it it is Messier but
chocolate isn't just making people horny
it's also making a lot of money globally
it's a $140 billion a year industry and
at this point you might be sitting at
home thinking hold on I've seen this
show before this feels like it's going
to be one of those fun stories but is it
about to take a turn I got a jumbo bag
of fun-sized Snickers that I'm going to
be handing out to Tiny Iron Men elers
and Luigi's in around 48 hours are you
going to make that weird for me well yes
yes I am and also don't me half
of that bag is going to be gone by
Halloween and you know it but the reason
this is about to take a turn is for all
the money and happiness surround in
chocolate there is one group that
doesn't get to share in it and that is
the farmers who grow cocoa in the first
place the vast majority have never even
tasted chocolate and that is something
that reporters and documentarians love
to try and remedy on camera and perhaps
not as patronizingly as this these
Farmers have been growing beans for
decades they're about to get their first
taste of chocolate you have never tried
chocolate
no
that is your
Coco well well to those who thought that
I'm the most annoying version of a loud
man on TV with a British accent looks
like you owe me an apology because that
is pretty condescending right there
attention forward subjects we noticed
that you've not once tasted the fruit of
your interminable toil so allow me to
present you with a generous gift of a
single kid cat that is your C
go and the reason most Farmers haven't
tried chocolate before is they can't
afford it more than 60% of Coco comes
from just two West African countries
Ivory Coast and Ghana and researchers
have found that in those places between
73 and 90% of Coco farmers do not earn a
living income with 30 to 58% earning
below the world bank's extreme poverty
life and there's something a bit weird
about a product so synonymous for
spreading joy and giv giving babies
what's basically a cocaine Rush
abandoning those who grow its key
ingredient to grinding poverty because
even if you had a sense the Coco
production had issues the truth is from
the land it's grown on to the working
conditions of those Who harvest it it is
worse than you may realize so given that
as we prepare for our annual tradition
of stuffing as much of it in our faces
as humanly possible tonight let's talk
about chocolate and let's start with the
fact that Coco is mostly grown on very
small family run plots they're about
half a million of them in Ivory Coast
and another 800,000 in Ghana harvesting
cocoa pods is labor intensive and done
entirely by hand and by the way what's
inside them may not be what you are
picturing in your mind Evan's kenoi
cracks open the pods to extract the
sweet slimy Bean which at this stage has
a flavor like leechy fruit once the
cocoa is collected it's left to ferment
under banana leaves for about 7 Days
yeah that slimy bean soup is cocoa
chocolate starts out as gluey white
insect lava that comes out of a big tree
egg and it's only after a long process
that that fermenting forages becomes
something more appetizing or in the case
of a mountains bar even less
appetizing from the farm the Coco then
passes through a number of hands on its
way to the chocolate companies from the
people who collect the beans to the
warehouses who store them each of whom
gets paid for their part in the chain
but at a certain point they all feed
into one narrow bottleneck as this
expert explains in an almost unnervingly
soothing Way by a away the story of
chocolate is a little bit like an
hourglass where you have millions of
small holders growing cocoa at the very
beginning of the story and at the end of
the story you have millions of consumers
eating chocolate but right at the center
of The Hourglass are a handful of
extremely powerful companies these
companies are the Coco
Traders
okay that was a very good description of
how the industry works from what I can
only assume is a 9-hour YouTube video
entitled woman explains Coco sector
inequality ASMR fall asleep now high
quality headphones on but it is true the
industry is dominated by just a handful
of Coco trading companies the most
powerful of which are the so-called big
three Cargill Barry calbot and ofi which
together buy and Pro about 60% of the
world's cocoa they then sell to a
handful of major chocolate companies
Mars mes which owns cabry Ferrero nesle
and Hershey which together sell over
half the world's chocolate and when you
have so many farmers and so few buyers
the buyers clearly have a big advantage
that is why only about 6% of the value
of a chocolate bar makes its way back to
the farmer and look I'm not saying that
those companies aren't adding real value
to their part of the process they are
are this Halloween try offering a
Spider-Man a Kit Kat or a handful of
sticky white bean lava and see which
they prefer but there are clearly
massive disparities in who reaps the
benefits of this extremely profitable
industry and I will say there are
mechanisms in place to at least help
stabilize the amount that farmers earn
both Ghana and ivory Co set minimum
prices the farmers receive for their
Coco the problem is those prices are not
only difficult to enforce but crucially
they're often not enough to cover the
costs of farming and so some Farmers
most of whom remember are experiencing
extreme poverty have resorted to trying
to increase their earnings by growing
more cocoa on land that is protected by
the government which is illegal because
it can do significant environmental
damage desperate Farmers supplement
their crop by growing cocoa trees in a
protected Forest where the uncultivated
soil is more fertile and stolen land is
in effect free of charge What's Left
Behind is known as a skeleton Forest
okay let's face it it was only a matter
of time before the phrase skeleton
Forest appeared on this show because if
there is a Sinister combination of words
out there we're going to stumble over it
tumor elections ghost abuse murder
pollution stay tuned all those are
coming up but it's not just
environmental damage there is also
significant human cost in Coco farming
which has been well known for a while
around 20 years ago a series of news
stories and a documentary found that
young children some of whom had been
enslaved or trafficked were working on
Cocoa Farms that supplied major
chocolate companies and in the wake of
public horror over this companies didn't
do themselves any favors with how they
responded just listen to the answers
that this Dutch journalist got when he
asked Nestle about whether children were
involved in making its chocolate
children are working in virtually every
single agricultural uh uh setup around
the world yes okay as a matter of fact
when I was 11 or 12 years old I went to
help a farmer I did not get paid paid
for it I did it because I I thought it
was it was uh fun that was child labor a
child working and that's the same it's
not the same it's evidently I didn't I
didn't need to do that okay yeah right
not to stress the most obvious point in
the universe but doing something for fun
isn't the same thing as doing it to
survive is the difference between being
in an escape room and being in a Saw
movie sure they're both equally bad
first date ideas but that is where the
similarities end and look I'll give him
this a lot of child labor does consist
of kids working on their own family's
Coco Farms though even in those cases
they can be doing so in hazardous
conditions and also watch as that Nestle
spokesperson accidentally walks into a
pretty damning admission of exactly why
they might have been having to do that
in the first place for a poor farmer in
in in in Africa often the help that he
gets from his children is vital in order
to maintain the standard of living of
the family because they they because
they are so desperately poor because
they don't get paid enough by Nestle or
by the companies they work for that's
thank you very much wow it is very funny
to me that he thought ending that call
when he did was somehow avoiding
implicating himself look the farmers
have to make their children work for
them because they are so poor because
they're not paid a living wage by Nestle
the company that I you know what nice
try you're breaking up I'm going through
a tunnel goodbye that was a close one I
think I got away with it and again it's
not just kids working on their family
farms children have been known to be
forced or trafficked to work in Cocoa
production while because of the nature
of this crime exact numbers aren't known
one survey estimated that in Ivory Coast
over a 4-year period 2,000 children were
victims of forced labor while in Ghana
it was
14,000 and back in the 2000s outrage
over this actually spurred us lawmakers
to take action first they considered
mandating labels for chocolate
indicating whether or not it was made
with child slave labor but the chocolate
industry then lobbied that down to a
voluntary agreement to eliminate the
worst forms of child labor promising to
get it done by July 2005 that agreement
later became known as the harken Engle
protocol after the two lawmakers who had
pushed for it but when the deadline
rolls around Senator Hawkin had this
unfortunate update though I was
disappointed that the July 1st deadline
was not fully met by the industry they
have given us a commit a commitment to
achieving a certification system which
can be expanded across the Coco growing
areas of West Africa and which will
cover 50% of the Coco growing areas of
Ivory Coast and Ghana in three years
time I am very pleased
with this commitment wait are you
because if so I genuinely jealous of
your infinite capacity for trusting
others ah I see from the first panel of
today's Peanuts comic that Lucy is
finally going to let Charlie Brown kick
the football while I was disappointed by
her actions in the past it seems that a
new day has brought a sense of Integrity
within this young girl and I'm very
excited to move my gaze down the page
and see this commitment honored in while
she did it
again and predictably the companies
didn't meet that new deadline either
once 2008 rolled around they kicked it
to 2010 then pushed it again to 2020
while simultaneously downgrading their
goal to just getting a 70% reduction in
child labor rather than eliminating it
entirely then they missed that deadline
too and the companies almost certainly
knew that they wouldn't be keeping their
promises here as the former head of the
international Coco initiative put it was
there any chance of child labor being
eradicated by the original 2005 deadline
no never and at that point why bother
selling a date at all if your friend
agrees to meet you for dinner at 700
then pushes it to 7:30 then 8 and then
finally says be there in 20 years not
minutes it kind of feels like they never
had any intention of getting dinner in
the first place and I will say it is not
like the chocolate companies have done
nothing they all started flashy looking
programs with Coco in their names that
promised to be vigilant about monitoring
for child labor and they produced
impressive looking ads featuring happy
farmers and websites showing how
carefully they monitor their supply
chain but the reality hasn't remotely
lived up to the rhetoric just last year
some journalists looked at a map of
farms on meles's Coco life website and
then sent a camera crew to GH to check
some out and you'll never guess what
they found it didn't take long to find
children working on a farm matching the
coordinates listed on the Coco life
website the team filmed two to young
boys age 10 and 11 harvesting cocoa pods
using long sticks with sharp hooks and
wearing no protective clothing it's true
they went to just one of the Farms
listed on their site a site filled with
claims that child labor is completely
unacceptable and instantly found child
labor and I don't know what statement
meles can release in the wake of that
other than maybe honestly did not think
anyone would actually
check and you think well obviously we
can't trust companies to monitor
themselves that's why there should be a
third party involved the thing is those
have also existed for years chocolate
companies have long purchased at least
some of their beans from third-party
organizations like these who certify the
farmers who Supply them have met certain
child labor and environmental standards
you might have seen one of these logos
on a chocolate bar and felt reassured by
it but while Advocates say that some of
these organizations have improved
conditions somewhat these logos just
aren't the guarantee that you might want
them to be for a start while the
organizations pay Farmers a small
premium for meeting their standards
those premiums might not even cover the
cost of complying with the program but
also typically inspections for the
labels are required of fewer than one in
10 Farms annually and just watch what
happened when reporters went undercover
as Chocolate Company Executives and
visited a contractor who did audits for
OOTS one of those thirdparty
organizations because he explains to
them exactly why he is so confident that
he won't find child labor on any farm
that he
visits
the audit is announced in advance you go
and visit producers who know that you're
coming when you go to them you are not
going to see any children that is true
Auditors give advanced notice of
inspections which is clearly ridiculous
because that's never going to be
reliable if you tell your teenager I'm
checking your backpack for cigarettes
next
Tuesday then great news you're not going
to find any now I have to tell you OTS
has maintained that it holds Auditors to
the highest standards although you have
just seen those standards and I don't
know about you but they didn't seem that
high to me as for mes who remember
turned out to have child labor at one of
its supplies in Ghana it said that it
was deeply concerned by these incidents
and okay that makes two of us
mes it also wants you to know that it
has a child labor monitoring system in
place to prevent this kind of thing from
happening which is very reassuring until
you remember it only took a documentary
crew one flight to GH to prove that that
system is at best deeply inadequate and
that is the thing all these companies
will say that they are concerned about
child labor and that they've spent a lot
of money trying to fix it by one
estimate as of 2019 they spent more than
$150 million to address this issue but
that's over 18 years and while they were
collecting 103 billion in sales annually
meaning that over two decades they've
spent just
.1% of one year's sales and come on
M&M's must have spent more than that
fine-tuning exactly how the
green &m
is and and for all the company's claims
of concern the fact remains according to
the US Department of Labor an estimated
1 and a half million children work in
Coco production in Ghana and Ivory Coast
many of whom are engaged in dangerous
tasks or as a Washington Post
investigation concluded the odds are
substantial that a chocolate bar bought
in the United States is the product of
child labor in fact the Persistence of
it in the supply chain is an Open Secret
just watch as some young workers end up
joking about it when asked by visiting
[Music]
journalists
oh yeah we all fondly remember being 21
small frame childlike voice another guy
has to constantly remind you that you're
21 just classic early 20s stuff and I
know they were laughing there and that
clip was honestly kind of charming but
the truth is for others the stories are
pretty harrowing like this young girl
who said that at this point she'd
already been farming Coco for 5
years I was brought here by my aunt I
was told I would be helping with the
baby but instead I only do farming she
says she wants to go to school but her
uncle can't afford to send her my uncle
says he struggles to pay for his own
children so if I join them he will not
be able to buy the school books we asked
if she misses her family yes do you hear
from them no have you ever been back to
visit them since you came here no
that is heartbreaking and the truth is
there are a lot more Clips out there
like that one than there are of kids
joking around about being 21 and at this
point you might be wondering well what
can we do differently and I will admit
it's really complicated child labor in
these regions is caused by a myriad of
issues from poor infrastructure to
limited access to education but to a
significant extent it is caused by
poverty a poverty that is actively
perpetuated by these chocolate companies
and if they really want to remedy things
a good first step would simply be to pay
Farmers more and companies might bulk at
that saying that they don't set the
price the market does but as this
Advocate points out that's a pretty
lousy excuse every Trader and every
multinational I speak to always say oh
but that's the world market price we
have no influence on that at all but you
buy a quarter of the world's cocoa beans
how can you not influence the price
exactly and look I am no Economist
despite winning most likely to be an
economist based on appearance back in
preschool but if you buy that much of
the global Supply in something you
definitely have some sway over how much
it costs and the thing is there are
models here that companies could look to
remember that Dutch journalist making
the guy from Nestle squirm as a result
of that segment he actually created his
own Chocolate Company Tony's chocola
lonely it works hard to ensure that its
supply chain is free from child or slave
labor and importantly ensures that the
people who grow its cocoa are in dire
poverty here is its former head of
sustainability explaining how it sets
the price for the beans that it buys we
calculate how big the Gap is between the
government set price and the living
income price and we pay that Gap as an
extra
premium for the spring harvest the
premium was about $63 higher than what
set by the government meaning Tony's
paid almost double for each bag of beans
that's great and it says something that
Tony's Were Somehow able to pay farmers
double the going rate despite being a
midsize Dutch Coco company whose logo by
the way looks like a casual dining
restaurant operated by and for
clowns if these guys can do it there's
frankly no reason why these guys can't
as well and to be fair even Tony's own
website admits the scale of the
challenge here saying we have never
found an instance of modern slavery in
our supply chain however we do not
guarantee our chocolate is 100% slave
free while we are doing everything we
can to prevent slavery and child labor
we are also realistic and I have to say
I appreciate that because there is a
difference between recognizing how much
there is to do and simply not doing
enough and I know these are companies
not Charities whose job it is to make
money and not save the world but that
means that they will only care about
this problem exactly as much as they are
forced to so if we are serious about
getting child labor out of our chocolate
we can't keep relying on Pinky promises
and the honor System we need tough
legislation that requires companies do
the right thing and it's not like this
is the only industry where exploitation
in other countries is the norm I could
just as easily I've done this piece
about coffee or palm oil and we actually
talked about trafficking and child labor
in the US farm system this year but
experts themselves say of chocolate in
few Industries is the evidence of
objectionable practices so clear the
industry's pledges to reform so
ambitious and the breaching of those
promises so obvious we have known for 20
years what the problems are here and we
haven't bothered to fix them but if we
do then imagine this one day maybe just
maybe we can get back to a point where
chocolate can once more give us the
simple uncomplicated Joy of
this
exactly